Y
AND
>> DR. ANTHONY
BA ODE BCR HANDLING OF THEEMW A
>> TRECION THE SWA
ASKS.
THEN HE SAID MASKS.
LE GIVFLASH.
TH'SAY SCIEN WWOE
AT T ON
YOMEEDN E S
IT IS A SELF CORRECTING PROCESH
ABT  AY SCIENCIT WAS NOTE BECAUS
G. AE BECAUSE THE
EVIDENCE CNG. CHEON END T  ME
NOW,A IS
I THINK WH'SHI PK E
INCREASING NOW ALMOST BY THE
I'M WONDERING WHY YOU THINK THAT
W HE'TTING ATTACKED
EVEN MORE ALL DAY LONG AND THE
NAMES HAVE BEEN --
CALLED HITLER, FLIP FOUCHI.
I MENTIONED ALL THE NAMES TO HIM
T A NIGHT A BUNCH OF
SENATORS AND CONGRESSMEN WERE Y
PRTIC FOR HIM AND
PROBLEMATIC TO DO HIS JOB
BECAUSE THERE ARE STILL MANYINAL
HAVEN'T BEEN VACCINATED ANE
S AREN'T UP.OT
VIRUWIED D SECONDLY, HE HAS BECH
A LINCHING BAG AND
THINK HE'S SORT OF
ESPECIALLY WHEN  H
DIDN'T DO ANYTHING PER SE.
DK THIS GOING
TO CHANG T
THIS.
DID HE THINK CHANGE IN
ADMINISTRATIONS WOULD SOMEHOW
GET HIM OFF THE HOOK?
>> NO, I'M NOT SO SURE ABOUT
EAD HE WOULDE
A FLASH POIND IS BEING USE
IN THAT WAY.
IT MAKES SENSE BECAUSE HE IS SO
WELL KNOWNECOMSU A
FIGURE O
HAVE BEEN.
IN THIS CASE, I DON'T THINK HE '
IT JUST FEELS LIKE SOME OF THE
AR AND
THESEM THAT WERE
DISCOVERED.
THE AD O
THEM.
TH T
INAB
FOPU HEAH OFFICIAL
OFFICIALS TO, I DON'T WANT TO
SAY MAKE MISTAKES, THAT'S NOCOR.
THAT THEY KNOW SOMETHING AT THE
TI OXPLAIN
IN TIME WOULD HE GIVE DIFFERENT
YOU CAN'T GO BACK IN TIME.THE
YOU GIVE THE ADVICE KNOWINATT SY
CRITICISM FROM RIGHT BECAUSETHEG
ANYTHING STICK ON JOE BIDEN SO
THG TO FAUCI
INSTEAD.
CALLING.EDUTE
AND YOU DID BRING THAT UP.THG
POINTS ABOUT DR. FCIE
VERY LITTLE WEIGHT  E ULATION,I
CONDEMNING ME.NOW THR THING IS T
GETSREPOSTEROUS.
AND THE THINAT BOTHERS
ST IMPT  YOU
GETTING DEATH THREATS.
TERS AND YOUR
FE THREA
TEG NOTES IS
NOT FUN.
SON'T SAY THATSNTH
MEANREY W
POLITICAL IT IS.LIKE FAUCI ILIKA
ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
INTHIS IN A DISPASSIONATE HAS GW
ARE THE  TALKING ABOUT?
HEREUY WHOSENTIRLIFEENW YOU'RE E
>> OBVIO NOTHINGO
DO WITH HIS VIEW SCIENCE.
OF COURSE IT HIM.
>>EACOURSEABSOLUTELY.
I THINK  DIT DOES.
WD.C. YESTERD TRYING TO GETTOE
NUMBERS UP
AND HE WASD BY
SECURITY.
THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS, THIS
FOMENT DANGER TO HIMSELF
AND HI.
HE HAS WORKE PUBLIC HEALTH
ER THE YEARS.
I THINK HE'S SORT OF SHOCKED BY
THESE AND EVEN IS STILSHOCKED B
TAKEN OVER THE MISINFORMATIOJUSR
'T CORRECT AT TH
BEGINNINOF IT.S THINKING EIT'S L
AT HE SAID.
YOU CAN'T HAVE AENT DEBATE
ABOUT WHATO D THAT'S WHAT I THIR
HE HIS FAMILY,